right we are live welcome to the iron
Lords podcast episode number 28 and it's
another glorious Sunday and we are back
at the roundtable on the Lord's Day I'm
very excited about our special guests so
we're gonna get right into it I want to
introduce the Lord who I consider a
young phenom based on itself as a
meteoric rise in these YouTube gaming
streets he always provides high quality
content in a clear concise and balanced
manner yet it's never afraid to ruffle a
few feathers with his brutal honesty
falsely accused as it traded to a
specific platform this Lord continues to
shine with the support from real gamers
his great indie reviews and his
undeniable passion for video games
introducing mr. soft-serve himself the
host of the Xbox 2 podcast one of the
top 5 dead or alive content creators
already and the man with the middle you
sitting on the achievement iron throne
MAME Lord red outdoor how are we doing
sir that has to be the best intro I've
ever heard ever for myself Lord Ram
that's amazing
baby man you know it I know it's the
Lord's Day but it's also my day cuz
today is my birthday
and we got to show you we love what
you're doing out here and when you're on
and you have the round table when you
consider you and Lord at which you do
swing in the realm of the Lord's we have
to show that prop works pleasure to have
you
well it's a pleasure to be on I've
always wanted to come on your Gadget
Show because I I think you guys have had
like Tim dog on a couple other people I
like how you like you like you said
everybody's a lord and their domain and
I always find that to be incredibly cool
thank you thank you much appreciate it
and of course we have the usual suspects
at the round table
my co-host with the
most my brother from another mother in
the house of the young wolf mommy
Lord addict how are we doing sir I'm
still getting used to that how the young
wolf pretty good can't complain tired
but you know that's every Sunday good
schedule soon football season's coming
and of course our most technical gaming
Lord the solo gamer who lives for the
single-player experience semi offline
ps4 pro Illuminati mommy
Lord sovereign how we doing sir
fantastic doing great dragging my feet a
little bit long light long night last
night but it's good and I know why of
course
the excess gamer oh the Lord who is a
man of his convictions in the maze
nothing less than the premium experience
boxing takes by the way be lovely no
I'll be doing it was a great night
combat sports
you had the regular edition for those
people that you know couldn't do the
premium they had the Cotto Kobayashi
that was fantastic
you even had the free fights on Fox I
hope you got it all in but if you wanted
that premium tastes that haunted doll I
experienced that Mayweather McGregor it
lived up to everything I thought it
would live up to it was fantastic again
you saw a master boxer in his element
doing the things that he does we have
laid the rest the superiority
you know hopefully we can either stop
this talk the box is dead fantastic and
for all those that indulge in our
premium experience much love goes out to
you guys this is Lord Kings day he's
waited a long time here my Kivar went at
it shine all that I'm breathe combats
what it was a great night and of course
it is law kognito here spreading that
gaming realness on the ILP not telling
you what you wanna hear but what you
need it so before we get into what the
Lord's are playing we want to first
start off with a lore in this video game
history what inspired the Xbox to but
more importantly also that quest for the
million I want to know about that game's
core stuff so let's start with your
video game history was the first systems
you started we know you can't an Xbox
guy but was Xbox the first system video
game console the job no no no I mean I
was so most people people that are my
age probably his first system was the
NES at least nice at least didn't like
the memory banks right like I owned an
Atari and a colecovision but I don't
have you talking very oh gee talk I am I
just I just don't have any memories of
playing the Atari or the keulegan yeah I
can't remember what that [ __ ] look like
my first memory was we so I live in
Chicago Illinois shadow we had we had a
family cottage we would go to every year
in Wisconsin one summer we went there
and one of my best friends who lived in
Wisconsin I walked into his room and he
was playing the most beautiful thing
I've ever seen and that game was Mike
Tyson's punch-out
and I was transfixed and I needed it
and then I got it I got the NES for my
birthday with the triple pack you know
duck hunt Mario tracking healed and
punch-out
and so I mean it was essentially
punch-out Mike Tyson's punch-out that
started my video game love like that was
the first game I saw on the NES and I
love that game
nice that's a great thought so then from
the NES what did you transition to after
that I was a Sega kid afterwards I was a
CI male Lauren see I know you had
something going obviously I respect that
so now will you Genesis era will you
master what what era was Vanessa Sarah I
had a Sega CD so I played the classics
like my trap and sewer shark
I had a 32x
I had like a hundred Genesis games I was
a big Joe Montana football fan but you
know Lee my brother played the
terminator video game if you remember
that like this is EEP stuff right but uh
I do have a question though
but there's the fanboy in the comment
section anchorman wants know how since
today's my birthday I am officially 36 a
lower happy birthday man happy birthday
yes sir crazy a lot of people say they
got a catch up to you in Korea gave us
going and that's nothing this is good so
oh man my game if in my gamer score
included like every console from every
gen you wouldn't be able to cuz like I
had I had 150 Nintendo NES games I had
over a hundred Genesis games you know
like this judges me like I love playing
as many games as I possibly can of
course when that translate the gamer
score because he get more gamer score
buy more games you play that it's always
been me even as a little kid I wasn't I
wasn't you know cool with just playing
one game I had to play all the games so
they know after that I mean what when
did you start your first you gotta zoom
you got the original og Xbox correct
yeah but at the very end so after
Genesis I became a PlayStation fan I
became a PlayStation fan boy oh my god I
was so heavy in the PlayStation
I thought Sony creator confirmed no
wrong I got the PlayStation 1 I got the
PlayStation 2 plate PlayStation 2 still
on my favorite consoles ever and then I
actually I actually didn't like Xbox
I thought they I didn't I didn't let
them in gaming originally because I was
like PlayStation get out of here I
didn't I didn't get an OG xbox until
halo 2 came out cool I fell in for the
hype I picked up an OG xbox got halo 1
thought it was extremely overrated I
didn't understand what the light was
about got a skyrim Kotar which is no sky
every 15 years too early and then halo 2
I fell in love with dude like it was
Haley who was my first taste of online
gaming yes and I played halo 2 every
single day for like 13 hours a day for
an entire year
mmm remember how amazed we all would
like we heard proximity chat yeah for
the first time playing like a halo halo
2 or I'll just amaze my stuff like that
just being online with your friends
stuff those are memories man I was a
great game no absolutely cool so then
that didn't had transition to 360 and
I'm assuming and 360 because I wanted to
play Halo 2 upscaled and then I mean I
had a Gamecube is why do all three
systems and that gen and then I only
owned a 360 for the entirety of that Gen
Y had a week cuz everybody else had a
week but it wasn't really mine and then
yeah then the Xbox one ps4 but in game
this is very premium talking appreciate
Gaming shame as I've never I've never
owned an SNES and I've never played a
single SNES game
don't feel bad we now now as far as not
playing an SNES game though that part
I'm a little surprised but you've never
played an SNES game no because like like
you know I was a Genesis kid they would
enemy my 25 year old self has played
this if he gets it was always I was
always going forward so like I've only
owned Nintendo products I've owned a
Nintendo and the NES and a Gamecube like
so you skip that one yes and yes I'm
very confused by the SNES the 64 like we
would go over to my buddy's house and we
would play WCW versus NWO I just didn't
own one myself
the actual question um what made you buy
the Gamecube
I was $99 and came with Metroid Prime
and I'm like God me was Luigi's Mansion
I don't know why but I wanted to play
that game Joe that game was so good
right I really loved that game that's
like one of my favorite games I wish
they would make a true sequel not what
they tried to do well they told my don't
want on the 3ds I don't talk about the
one another 3d thing doesn't exist kind
of like the Death Note movie don't exist
to me so far your consoles right now
when did this whole quest become the man
with the million when did that start
how did it start I I mean I've I fell in
love with the Chi Minh's probably right
away right when I played call duty 2 and
that the achievement unlocked I'm like
what is this and I played the game on
veteran to beat it to get all the points
which I never work done
like I always had played games just on
the normal setting or whatever the
default setting was so I went out of my
way to play in a veteran and then I
started just seeking out games to play
like like games I wouldn't play games no
man should play like to get the lowest
moves talking about picking up that
Barbie game to get that achievers me
Lord ha ha would rent games just to put
up game score and we were going at each
other
renting demos whatever games we could
possibly get just outdo each other that
night and we will talk crap back and
forth but then when I saw it with your
game of school was I actually just fell
out of the race Lord reyne score so then
you can continue with the millionaire so
you got you got kind of addicted you
started that whole process and then it
just kept going it just stockpile they'd
like well yeah but then but then
cheating happened to get hind the
leaderboards and it was wrong
there was websites we could download
people saves and get the all the
achievements in like 10 seconds there is
no glitching and me and my friend
stallion 83 who's currently number one
in gamer score we kind of like that's
how we met was through our distaste of
people cheating the system we became
friends and we played like all the games
together back in the day and I didn't
think anything would really come of it
because I didn't think Microsoft would
bother doing anything about it but then
they did they took action they reset
people
you know they said you shouldn't do that
and by resetting people my position on
the leaderboard kept on going up and up
and up and up to the point where
eventually down the road I was like hey
like I could be top 5 which is the only
ever go I really want it like I didn't
care about being number one I just
thought like wouldn't it be cool to be
top 5 you know at some point and
absolutely I kept on grinding I passed
up a bunch of people to finally get into
the top five and even though I didn't
hit a million in the top five because I
had to wait to fill fill we can't fill
mentioned doing the million at e3 but he
it was like December side to wait like
six months so I wait in the in the
process of waiting for the moment I got
passed up by two people that were behind
me what's but a you know I'll take e3
you know exactly
Jessica Chobot the perks that come with
that is that's cool and you know it's
just real cool I felt that uh Xbox
recognized you you know as far as that
level of dedication and stuff like that
so that's really cool always being cool
with you know promoting like community
members and things like that in a way
that Sony doesn't bother with you know
that you know initially you was against
them but now they support you well the
reason I got a reason I didn't get a ps3
was because and even though I was
waiting I'm like ah let's see what's on
he's doing with the ps3 Sony was like oh
well our fans will buy anything that our
fans would would buy if the system was
just a brick and came no front no games
our fans would buy it I'm like you
called me dumb you know like and then
they're like you got to get a second job
done like so I'll wait no like I'm not
spending $600 I'm not like I don't like
this Eric
Sonne who is talking down about their
consumers and I'm like I'm out of here
you know ideas the same problem with
Xbox though around 2012-2013 though oh
yeah walk in that say oh we got a
product for you so 360 that's cool last
question real quick um now I know you
are good friends with our friend Lord
Jes Gordon and the Xbox 2 podcast so
before I actually ask you about that um
I wanted to pour out a little liquor
with Al out for a TX oo podcast which
you remember of and I was a huge fan of
that but um what then started the UM the
Xbox to like what was the u.s. so let's
started Xbox to was mean jazz would you
know we would DM quite a bit and then
sometimes we would have these long
conversations on skype like hours worth
right and we were just talking one day
and it was just like man nobody's would
hear these great gaming conversations
and he was like we should kind of start
a podcast I'm like yeah we should and
that's where it started from we were
like you know let's just take these
Skype you know conversations that we
have and just put it on YouTube and
that's how the Xbox 2 started nice yeah
you guys drop some great gems and you
cool inside information I was in my
feelings when you got shot down on me a
lot attics August Scorpio rumor but we
had to hold it I remember I remember I
started that rumor I was the one who
said that someone else also said he's
but you know but we appreciate what you
do that's really cool so we are going to
move on what the Lords have been playing
this week so let's start with uh Lord
addict what haven't you been playing
Sweet Escape
you know as much as I hate to say this
making my selfish finish sunset
overdrive and that's pretty much all I
got a finished sunset over job this week
because Mario rabbits comes out Tuesday
so
so does the record definitive edition
yes I'm gonna replay it nice nice and oh
lord serve what have you been touching
this week uncharted lost legacy I'm
gonna try to finish that up this coming
week and then playing more sonic mania
trying to get through that so that's
pretty much Lord King what have you been
touching this week Oh to Lord
addicts delight I've been playing Halo
Wars - wow I must say you know I love
the game the first one you know there's
a lot of dramatic changes that they put
towards the game and it enhances the
game it makes it afresh a new game I
really like the direction that they went
in with it and I have to say I gotta get
the hands down - like thank you so much
for telling me to get all the premium
content with it because honestly
seriously I would purchase it little by
little and it would add it up to like
five bucks individual or you can just
pop in 30 for all for you yet as far as
challenging you understand that your
world versed in these worlds this is
true but also play the Madden yeah I'm
getting to that later but yeah that's
what I gave Eric is respect and play
their game so just still hash tag killed
the backlog as you know the huge destiny
fan and when September comes all the
backlog is gonna stop and destiny will
take my soul once again but being that
we on this subject of kill the backlog
it's come to my attention through some
sources of mind that uh obviously I'm
trying to go for the achievement but red
I'm trying to go to win my first
achievement month right he's ahead of
you
there's not been a good month for me I'm
not coming I'm not even trying to
challenge the kind through how it feels
you don't had to throw them for a month
you know and then be done with it but
it's come to my attention through some
sources that a good friend of the
podcast
Lord Megatron has been sneaky creeping
up on my school and these last four
remaining days but now I have to get
into action and I got about a 600
gamerscore lead so may the best man win
but now I have to implement tactics so
we are getting too liquidy employee NZ
topics we'll get into what the whole so
a lot around last week we had a big poll
and the poll results are in the people
have spoken to the xbox regime and
leadership question whose model and
vision for Xbox do we prefer the most
the choices were a calm long term vision
services approach of Phil Spencer be the
aggressive for exclusives III tattoos in
high budget spending of Peter Moore or
see the big-budget marketing for games
TV and media approach of the Don miss
blackly commented on this poll that is
poured on what he saw there is 52%
strong in one of the most controversial
Iowa polls ever the chat was lit his
xbox only begotten Son our Lord and
Savior it was closed because Peter Moore
finished at second and raised it was 45%
a lot of the three six
the era guys were hitting this pole I
mean it would people with eating into
arguments on the ILP Twitter with each
other about Peter Moore versus Phil it
was hot Navy and finishing third place
with a whopping 4% name and shame he
actually voted but I know we've had kid
on the show before and he's a big bad
chick fed I think we had like a
discussion about whose era did we like
better and I know he did stage so I'm
gonna assume what are those votes I mean
you know Peter Moore was some special
man like that man could sell anything
like Patrick Don Mattrick always to me
just was like a used car salesman yes
got this car I want you know this but
like Peter Moore was a consummate
professional I always enjoyed his
presentations and then I think he's more
of a showman than Phyllis yes aggressive
and full of energy and respect and I'm
saying cuz I got me listen we all know
what the hand phil was dealt and what
he's done transformed this thing is
Ramon I actually think in Phil's defense
no one's probably had that much
adversity at the start of a job you know
so I gotta I gotta give that to fill out
you know at first I was in my feelings I
am a Peter Morgan but look the people
spoke man Phil Phil's the chin so we
gotta give it up to Phil right now this
is his day Phil if you listened it felt
there was a dealt aloe payer going to
get a pool house to those four percent
voted for done remember that toe it
organs to buy a 360 if you want to get
on but anyway
all 300 participated in a poll so um
we're gonna get right into these topics
so you know what addict you want to talk
about maybe Xbox fear the list part two
did you get for the roundtable well
there's this list that you know I know
ran has a lord ran made a video on this
list that's been surfing around and you
know the list is kind of like bizarre
and I don't know why anyone would
believe this thing exists it has like it
has I think it's six on both on both
years isn't it ran six both years I
think it's eight actually Oh God there
was there was the three games four games
we know just up for next year was uh see
thief state of decay crackdown Ori Forza
horizon for halo and I think there was
another one yeah oh and uh Ninja Gaiden
engine gate 8 on 8 for both years trying
to find a picture of it right actually
have a picture of here share the screen
actually what I mean when it comes to
this list it's like look like you know I
feel like whoever made this list like
they did they they try to go into that
oh I'm gonna press conference Iker talk
meeting press conference at Gamescom and
and somehow no one saw me record this
with my phone so you know what it comes
down to it's like look like you know
people are going to obviously come up
with some logical stuff that they want
people to think is logical by the other
day it's they just taking advantage of
people wanting you know news when it
comes exclusive wise y-you know give you
enough not to cut you look big revisited
Chet he said is this fear the list plot
to Lord King what's up the reason that
that first Federalist came out because I
thought there was a logical stuff for
Sony did you know what they was gonna do
and he didn't have to do it um because
Microsoft didn't push their hand
and Phil there again and you know in
control and he keeps these guys in place
by playing his hands silently um this
list I don't know is plausible
I looked at it but the one thing that
stood out to me is a red flag with ninja
gaiden click on click on my icon down
there I'm screen sharing
alright but I mean you know it's got
seed thieves and March 16th which I do
think some of these release dates could
be plausible like you know maybe not
towards the end because you know first
off we have no clue what's come out in
October I don't think it's ninja gaiden
that's for sure I don't think Halo would
come out in November and then like when
you look down here the December 6th 2019
with that rising like first off like I
don't think they would word it like that
ok I don't think they're gonna put 5 in
the name like that but you know that I
digress
uh just because dead rising for came out
in December does not mean every dead
risings come out in December so that's
that's a fellow ok
I think they should learn their lesson
from that don't ever do that again yeah
dark tie is supposed to come out in
September the 27th no clue what that is
and then you know you know you got your
Forza horizon 7 we know that's our they
are right knows a lot yeah I mean those
you know crackdown stated a--casey
thieves I could see those release dates
around that time or he's not coming out
next year you know it like the one thing
it's like they don't like it's not of
things like they have like set release
dates for Games two years away you know
yes like that's a giveaway and it's it
reads like fan fiction it's like perfect
just for people being like oh man to
bring it back cruising skies took the
like the the the MCU Tempe
they would make presentations
like Lord addicts at orys 2019
I almost my gut feeling my god this is
what my gut tells me so this is not any
insider information
I think crackdown gets delayed till
holiday next I said that I know he's
dead let me ask you this question only
if that is the case can they survive
that blody
I mean now if you say how are you
talking yeah maybe like September
October like my kind of process is the
thing people want to see is the thing
they aren't shown to anybody ever like
neck cloud the cloud destruction what do
we seen that we've we haven't seen it
hanging their hat on to that so unless
they have some special event next year
just to show it off before the band
comes out I think I think they'll
quietly just say they'll need more time
they'll show it off at e3 and then have
it like re-emerge at e3 and they show
off this awesome destruction trailer
take everybody hike and then oh it comes
out in October I think what you get is
because they already have two games
scheduled to come out before I see if
he's a state of decay - I'm not sure
they want to also sort of crackdown in
there at the same time because the next
year's pack you got far cry 5 yeah got
the crew - you have Red Dead Redemption
too far away yeah far away from it so
Microsoft they like they need see
thieves has to be a success and they
needs the proper breathing room and he's
the proper release state state of decay
to the June release state seems
plausible just be from the fact that I
think stated the k1 came out in June I
hope that's not true though I'm not
gonna lie because if I do decide that
kind of fear I'm gonna be very upset
comedy why their business even to wait
that long would suck oh it's not even
that like imagine it's like you know I
know you guys gonna need three next year
but like if I go I'm gonna be heated if
on that III and stage education play
well I remember when we with the first
year I went to e3 they were like uh halo
wars two Vedas right now I'm like this
is ridiculous
what if it's play anywhere it'll work
out because you can take your laptop and
get busy
Forza horizon for you know that seems
plausible if they make a four is it next
year which they they should you know I
don't know because I know play playback
is making another game I don't know if
that's gonna affect four is this
development cycle shouldn't but you know
we've seen a lot of incidents where you
know Microsoft likes their developers
working on one game one game only so I
don't know how that's going
yeah I'm assuming a force is coming on
next year I will say though like I
really really hope the Ninja Gaiden
thing does happen because I feel like
that is a really good diverse title that
the xbox libraries listen it's no Ninja
Gaiden okay I don't know Ninja Gaiden
but just thinking about Team Ninja in
general we haven't seen neo come over we
haven't heard any talk about it a neo
definitive edition on X sounds fantastic
I don't know about an October release
date but it's something that we could
see come over I love ninja guy I mean I
think Neal Neal's done great on a ps4
for bringing her over to Xbox I think it
still scratches a ditch because it is a
faster sort of action game that with you
would you'd expect from like a Souls
game
it's even faster still than like a
blood-borne so I think it would be a
perfect fit I do have a question out of
these games that we know is coming out
for a fact you know year one obviously
what games they're you thinks gonna be
commercial success I think glory will be
well then again doors not next year but
halo here's the other thing I don't even
know if has to come out next year oh oh
you think an estimate I think
absolutely we need that we need we need
a holiday blockbuster cuz we had I hate
what you say it now my questioning when
was the what's the developments like the
one was halo five now so was twenty I so
numbered halo games for the most part
I've always had three year dev cycles
2001 for Halo one 2004 for Halo 2 2007
for Halo 3 2000 was a 2010 for reach or
2009 no in 2009 for ODST 2010 for each
and then Bungie left I was 2012 for Halo
4 and then 2015 for Halo 5 I do feel
like Halo 6 is an exception because they
did they did go back is supposedly and
redo a lot of how they were gonna do see
I'll take a reach for ODST in between
and wait and if they gave them hurry
yeah you know really done well they can
give you a good back story for has a
reach goes you know with spawn locks
team they can they can give you
something like that and give you a you
know a little flushes out origin of they
can yeah but you know when it comes down
to it like this bottom line that all
that all that right now when you think
you talk about anthem when do we think
anthem falls into thousands 2019 okay
guys I don't know they're pretty admin
is coming out like is elected everyone
everything's coming out in the year they
think it's coming out now your gut Lord
rain you think you think it might hit
the 2018 and from but you got saying
yeah my gut says anthem comes out next
year my gut says halo comes out next
year because like think about if halo
doesn't and that means halos 2019 does
that mean gears for I was 2020
halo is 2019 that pushes a lot of their
stuff back I just Microsoft needs but
this holidays better as much as I hate
to say we need a halo right now
like down on halo but halo stole
Microsoft's biggest franchise it's still
gonna sell millions I think it needs to
come out next holiday unless they aren't
gonna be ready and it's 2019 and they
slowly move crackdown 3 to be that
holiday game like I meant biggest
franchise it's how they make that oh
[Laughter]
that would mean based on Laura said you
got halo anthem in crackdown let's
theoretically say that they don't know
crackdown til III and it looks
completely different than we've seen so
far and the multiplayer is shown it runs
flawless exactly how they promised it to
us could it would that redeem what's
been going on with that title do I do
feel like you delay a game a certain
amount of time it loses hype and people
stop caring
when they finally release is of high
quality it doesn't matter when it comes
out except for except for November I
don't see it doesn't belong there and to
be honest halo doesn't belong there
anymore either
it just said if they show the
destructibility that we are craving and
we want to see and he presented better I
don't care how long it takes the height
will be deafening because then you will
see it to be justified you know the
weight is justified right if they show
the same thing that they've been showing
then the weighting justified in the game
won't so so just like Lord man said if
they show what we are asking for and I
believe so and I don't believe halo
comes out next year I think believe
crackdown takes that spot yeah I think
yeah but I'm with I'm with lost ass back
in the chat I mean I know what you guys
are saying in halos that ham alright ham
and Knox Turner but if they're marketing
anthem I don't think it's a good idea to
necessarily put both of those out in the
same yeah but I'm saying
they a date to PlayStation 5 not say I'm
gonna DJ but oh shout out to over 15 in
the chat y'all please hit that like
button you said that which game like
needs to be a success right
like I think the game looking at that
list that absolutely 100% needs to be an
unequivocal success to see thieves yeah
with you guys like I do think the
biggest thing hurt in that game is that
is that NDA like I really think that's
hurting it more that's protecting it I
mean yeah because you know like you know
I can't really say a whole lot when it
comes to that game and I enjoy it like
thoroughly when I play all those things
that obviously us all of us here in this
chat you know we've gone and around say
I'm gonna eat me I'm also touched or at
least played in some capacity and you
know from what I seen I'm like this game
could be something and the problem right
now is the messaging in my opinion no
one knows kind of like exactly what you
do but it's one of those things that
it's like when you get your hands on it
you're like okay you know I mean so I
think it's gonna be one of the things
that when it does come out people will
quote unquote get it but you know they
have to knock it out the park they can't
mess around with it so I guess I'm not
too upset with them with that I'm all
I'm listening I'm all on the side of
them taking their time getting all the
components and the aspects race what I
was thinking nice is is it finished I do
want to you know point out a comment
someone said Michael said have anthem
exclusive the Xbox I don't think that
would ever happen but you know they do
eat it they do need to go to EA it
dropped that check and get a similar
deal that that that Sony got with
destiny because cuz let's be real here
you know a lot of people don't give
destiny a lot of props when it comes to
its help the PlayStation along anytime
big time because they've had a bundle
every gin I mean every year they've had
a bundle with destiny I wouldn't be
surprised at destiny sold a couple
million PlayStation fours I agree what
you love act the only problem is based
on what we've seen and heard from Phil
and Lord ranked correct me if I'm wrong
he just doesn't seem to believe in that
exclusive content
paying deal anymore like he
seem to subscribe there what's the vibe
you getting from from fellow nose type
of the exclusive content deals when
Microsoft has the marketing I mean he's
been on podcasts and like shows where he
says he doesn't like want to pay for a
skin that other people can't get he's
against that stuff but um you know one
of the reasons that the Saudis killing
them right now well yeah well I mean
we've done again like the Destiny stuff
there may have been zero chance
Microsoft could ever get the desk oh
yeah right that's that's that's facts
like multi contra like same thing with
the Star Wars stuff cuz I heard I heard
that's more of deal with Disney between
between Disney and Sony than is Sony and
EA so a lot of these deals are
multi-year like to call of duty' deal
like there's nothing Microsoft can do to
get any deals because they might be
multi game multi year type of deals yeah
now we're talking about anthem but what
if anthem isn't a marketing deal with
Microsoft we ever think about that just
what if you're just assuming that it is
because Microsoft put it on their stage
from when I was told the deal only
pertained to e3 Microsoft a buttload of
cash to debut the game on their stage
correct as of now from what I understand
there's no marketing deal between Xbox
and anthem which is bait and switch be a
possibility Sony's like now we got this
game like we did the poll this is what
the Peter Moore contingent is saying
like like look why you not aggressive
these guys are coming that [ __ ] neck
with these exclusive marketing deals and
like you've got to do I don't I don't
even think it would be so bad if they
had exclusives dropping at the time
either that that's like the icing on the
cake it's like you know you've been real
lackluster this year when it comes to
you know exclusive content on your
console but then on top of that the big
blockbusters coming out this year also
was in the competition being marketed by
them right marketing
it was done right can be just as
effective as having an exclusive I agree
I do to some level I mean because the
casuals diligently don't you put that
like Sony he has Red Dead Redemption to
next year 5 which is also beginning of
next year like Sony is rolling around
their weight they are market leader a
lot of these companies are going to want
to naturally advertise what Sony you
know because they're number one a lot of
a lot of play people only want like well
if I'm gonna mark with someone I'm
marketing what the market leader right
thanks Sony gets like the cherry pick
you know and they didn't really have any
big-time exclusives this holiday so
they're like yeah well we know
Microsoft's got the X but will lock down
besten e2 will lock down cod will lock
down what else they got this holiday
well it was read that too but read that
to move but so now next dollar front
ring well they got Battlefront so but
then like you look at next spring
they're hitting you with far cry 5 which
is gonna be huge
they're getting you with read dead 2
which is huge then they're gonna hit you
with God of the more and more cradles
possibly spider-man and someone is
violating Sony's gonna be all over the
team's gone absolutely no yeah and see
what's breaking my heart loan rate is
that if what you say I really hope what
you think is about you even though
there's a very strong chance it could be
that if that anthem deal was just to
show it on the Microsoft stage and
there's no market that's a problem oh I
do not spend money on actual deals you
spend money to get it on your stage for
you know two minutes that serve like
what purpose does it serve you know
what's attitude the biggest part it
would have been more of an impact if it
wasn't even shown iease conference yep
but I digress
we have beaten this to death but
needless to say fear that less part 2 is
a bit in the comment section said I
spoke of air in a TA and I can confirm
they have a marketing do of Microsoft a
Q Lord Lord - thank you our Lord and
Savior
thank you for giving us some hope we
would hope that that is the case I
appreciate their Lord Cal coming down to
tick's finest coming down and giving us
some info there's a bigger move on to
the next topic you know Lord solo not a
lot of talk about these enhancements on
Xbox one X Games Gamescom stuffs what
you got to talk to it around - yes I
have a few few little things to talk
about last week I know we said we're
gonna come back and talk more about Xbox
at Gamescom and it just never came
together so talk a little bit about that
and what came out and people's feelings
on what they announced the gamescom
um so honestly from my perspective I I
expected a little bit more no Gamescom
hasn't traditionally been a show where
they show a lot of stuff um but I
thought with the with the delay of
crackdown we were gonna get just a
little more info maybe a few more big
surprises and I actually expected a
tried-and-true conference which is not
what we got we got this you know
sit-down thing um yeah a little
treehouse type thing and it just I don't
know I I wasn't very fond of it because
it just felt very sort of sort of
rehearsed and not you know kind of
disingenuous you always you had the one
guy like hooting hollering in the back
at the end of every trailer which was in
the trailers were regurgitated III
trailers so I just didn't think that
sort of didn't come off very well um in
terms of stuff they announced honestly
the most exciting stuff to me was just
finally that the x1x pre-orders are
going up Scorpio edition obviously which
we had seen beforehand I thought was
interesting um but in terms of actual
announcements it just it was kind of
underwhelming the Jurassic Park game is
cool the the building game I think it's
if there's a game if there's a franchise
that associates well with that sort of
game it would be that some sort of
SimCity thing so a Jurassic Park that
seems pretty cool um but again not
necessarily for me um the record
definitive edition words
[Music]
I'm ready for the definitive edition I'm
ready to actually completely complete
the game I was now finishing that barren
wasteland of a game barren wasteland you
put the time and beat the game you play
money I play games hundred plus a back
look says otherwise there's only one
premium experience Lord on this podcast
so but honestly I mean it was just sort
of underwhelming and maybe we were I
expected too much from it let's see if
thieves
the thief stuff coming way you know
cross play with with PC and stuff but we
knew kind of me that was coming so to me
the most interesting stuff besides the
Xbox one excellent stuff was the fact
that they finally got their hands on
seeing some x1x enhanced games and here
on this podcast we've been very critical
of them of how they sort of pigeon-holed
themselves by claiming all this you know
uncompromised 4k and how they put
themselves in a corner when any time any
game was not hitting those standards
they were up they were you put
themselves in a position to be
completely scrutinized and attacked
and what we saw with a lot of these
games on this list now of over 100 games
that are getting XY x enhancements a lot
of these games are going to be able to
hit native 4k um at 30 frames per second
or whatever or higher than 30 frames if
the game originally had an unlocked
framerate so it's kind of it's good to
finally get some concrete evidence that
what they were talking about was just
not completely smoke and mirrors and we
can have more confidence on what the
what the system is capable of I mean in
terms of the for the 4k stuff is
grateful to be honest I my thing is just
that the system be capable did the
system be able to give me you know a
great 1080p experience as well as a 4k
experience I to me that that's that's
the primary thing gotcha um so yeah like
all enhancements they had would like to
later especially to later either to me
that looks absolutely fantastic so to me
it did I did a good job of cementing in
the minds of people who already may be
on the fence about the X but leaning
towards getting it it gave a real reason
to be able to pick it up day one without
necessarily a big you know exclusive
game we cracked down not being there and
have confidence that the games that are
there are releasing around the launch of
the system and the games that they
already have in their library are gonna
look considerably better and run
considerably better so I think it did it
was a nice little boost for their
marketing in that regard first a shout
out to the 63 people watching shout it
to the 29 people that liked it and even
shout out to anchorman in his whatever
buddy he had to dislike the video some
like rival II between iron Lords
podcasts and the multiverse over there
that's the premium brick there's no
rivalry between anyone it's just I mean
so when it comes to games calmly look
like
you know even I expect a little bit more
than what they did because you let's be
real here at Gamescom when it comes to
caliber like the highest thing they've
ever got something like Tomb Raider you
know they have an out stuff like Halo
Wars - at these events but for the most
part they don't really announce anything
big you know what I knew this the people
had too much of high expectations when
it came to this conference this event
when it started in people said Oh once
the conference start is just the
pre-show I was done I like they're not
having a conference like no one knew
this what I hear is Gamescom is more of
an event as far as the atmosphere goes
um more so than III like we have to go
there we have to go to because what I'm
hearing you know from a couple of guys
there I was you know tweeting what a
couple guys they said the place was
opening and it's open to the public so
it's not as ingested as III was and they
had more stuff to do like as well as the
crowd stuff I don't know about
congestion cuz you're talking about
300-thousand Lord Jonathan citron it did
Chad say how would you guys feel if they
held back crack down three just to put
the halo six baby games called Oscar
oval fable legends cancel corner braid
didn't perform very well at scale bail
canceled I mean so I'm taking all of
these subjects everything we just talked
about like those the kind of
quote-unquote week showing that game
song and I'm gonna relate that back to
my choice in last week's poll which is
Peter Moore and make no mistake I love
two furless fantastic and I think for
the future of Xbox
taking in and focusing on services and
making that making Xbox the platform
that he wants to make it in the future I
get it I get it and I think it's
fantastic but like we just said Sony is
not taking the boot off their neck ever
and they can't be honest they could do
that because they're so far in the lead
and they don't every chance they get to
take the conversation away from Xbox
they do it and I think Peter that's what
I liked about Peter more mm anymore was
that showman Peter more as a marketing
guy first and foremost he's about he's
about the big spec section and he's got
that competitive nature yes he was like
I remember that Sony killed my Dreamcast
you know he had that vendetta like again
there's no disrespect if I could fill
the thing I like about Phil is he's a
game right and we love him for that we
love that he appreciates things and it's
the services that he provides you know
for gaming has been great the preview
program came past you know EA acts all
this stuff has been great it's just like
just from an aggressive competitive
standpoint sometimes I kind of dislike
when he's kind of like hey we like
everyone and hey I'm gonna play like
this I think he has to play this passive
role until he gets the upper hand he's
off the board and he's right now this
November when the Xbox becomes the most
powerful console I think you're gonna
start seeing aggressive tone from film
and it's gonna be an aggressive tone in
a sense that you're gonna start seeing
those games that he was talking about
that's coming and the way they're gonna
be marketed towards the power whatever
it's like I said it's like this is the
thing if a week before the Xbox one X
launches at Paris games week so when he
says yeah in March we're gonna talk
about the next step in PlayStation
hardware
just says that then what you know was
funny like that and that it was like the
PlayStation VR too and they just they
did it at Gamescom they did it at
Gamescom we talked about this last night
on the rgm podcast out to lady Bella but
I'm not having this on me but we talked
about it last night where they came out
said oh we have something to announce it
was covered up it was all hidden and
everybody said Oh what is it PlayStation
5 PS v r2 I mean the speculation was all
across the board and at the end of the
day it was just a Gran Turismo console
but for a day and a half
you have people speculate and Adam yeah
and then look you know you know xbox
isn't willing to do that I've said from
the start that my personal opinion I
think the you know people say oh the X
was made for the hardcore it was made
for the hardcore but I think secretly
was made to get rid of that power you
know oh yeah absolutely
and like you know people like all its
they they're not getting rid of the
power a narrative for the X they're
getting rid of it to free the s from the
ps4 because when the X is the strongest
console they can't promote the ps4 is
the strongest console anymore and that's
what's gonna sell the most so they're
trying to push more s's so you know the
X is like that that that person like the
the bigger brother that comes in between
the the younger brother with the bully
yeah they're like now you like you ain't
coming up in here like that so you know
they're trying to push more s is because
it's hard to promote the second
strongest console over the third
strongest console so you know they took
that narrative completely off the table
I see Lord ran out or we got to get you
in it you've been quiet I need your
opinion on these uh first the Xbox one X
enhanced game situation and then also
the the gamescom showing you know I know
you have like a video about that as well
well yeah so the Xbox one enhance game
stuff is what I've been waiting to see
oh well it'll perform and I feel games I
feel digital foundry is doing a better
job marketing Xbox one isomer swap is
creating I Pothier eyes in my video it's
because Microsoft doesn't
do any direct comparisons right now
maybe because any comparison between the
X and the s will automatically make the
s look like a terrible system and it's
still a system that they have to sell to
people correct currently like even
though yeah you're propping up the X by
saying look how much better it is
you're also damaging the other system
that you have because because you're
saying this new system is fire I think
they're trying to find a good balance
there right because they don't want to
they don't want to bury the s beneath
the power of the X so I'm excited like I
watched the digital foundry vid well you
could tell Richard and them were really
impressed by what they saw with the
system and that comes true and it makes
someone like me who doesn't know much
about tech and stuff like that that
makes me even more excited for this
system you know and I want to see more
like about you know other games like
yeah Tomb Raider great like but that's 2
year old game right it's a thanks 2015
who really cares I want to know about a
game that came out this year I want to
know about the game's gonna coming out
this year and then what it'll do for my
future games you know like that's what I
want and as far as Gamescom goes that
presentation wouldn't have existed if
they didn't need to push pre-orders that
that live like if approvers went live at
e3 or if they went live at some some
place some some timeouts they wouldn't
have even bothered doing that they
wouldn't have done it they would have
just completely skipped it because that
entire presentation was just a waste of
time it only served one purpose and that
purpose was to watch the show and get
people kind of excited and hyped for the
X I mean it's an Xbox alternative to
like what do you if you if you can't get
your pre-orders ready at e3 it's like
well
when is the next best logical thing to
do and it's like well Gamescom it's like
okay we'll do it at Gamescom because
there's a really a lot of sense to do it
any other any at any other point in time
right so they was like the idea was
we're gonna do it for pre-orders and
come up with an hour and a half worth of
stuff and you could tell they had
nothing like to come up with because
we're getting Jurassic Park but someone
says do you take - well they didn't say
but I'm asking do you think deaths
[ __ ] coming up by 2019 no I don't
know charter for the PS 5 you guys I'm
sorry like just a piggy bank on foot I
want to jump in just to piggyback off a
Lorentzian I mean I'm totally agreement
with him as far as the Xbox one at exit
hands game I think honestly this is the
route Microsoft has to take because of
the exclusive situation and I think
ideally I remember when they made the
announcement that the Scorpio would be
revealed through digital foundry I
thought that was a boss moment and I
thought that because they understand
that digital foundry is in the tongues
of that of the game is right there right
we line up to see when there's that
comparison video right and Microsoft has
been on the tail end of that early in
the generation you know when they go to
the Xbox one ports and the ps4 to 1080p
729 hundred P Fiasco's right so I
thought that was small and also felt
like okay they're confident in this
system they're getting Richard Ledbetter
and these guys to get on it hands on
touch this thing and really go at it so
that was the first thing you know as far
as the second part for us what I think
is really cool is that with these
enhancements I also want to see outside
of that list that's being shown that
looks great - made all that stuff I want
to see about this quote-unquote natural
boost mode for titles that are not on
the list because they should still
receive some type of an upgrade like a
guy like me I've talked about this law
soft we talked about it yesterday on our
REM fellows podcast you know about like
a game like a Tekken 7 that's not on the
list or stuff that have like bad low
times or
you know that even I think about this
young think about rice on the rule Oh
changes to see how that's gonna look you
know with it with an upscale or whatever
so I think this is the approach they
have to take by default because of the
exclusive situation as far as the games
come your I said it like a total addict
before that show started I'm like don't
get your hopes up I was like I'm not
expecting anything now as far as what
they showed I agree with Lord reyne this
isn't all about Capri yours right this
is all about getting the system out
there
I thought the Scorpio edition was really
cool you know
for me personally I was low you know
surprised I actually had other games and
stuff to show but you know my my main
thing with it that really just bothered
me though the only met really bothered
me to repeat on trailers yeah you cannot
reuse video assets from e3 that is a no
no it's like as far as okay I've said it
before it's like they packed up III was
like where you want us to put it just
hope I will use it in a couple months
I've you know was also interesting is
after after the comic-con showing for
crackdown on stuff and even e3 phil was
pretty adamant saying we'd see the
multiplayer disruption of crackdown at
Gamescom wasn't there it's not ready I'm
not mad you know it does it make you
wonder go for what what happened between
III where they gave us the dates and you
know that week were they delayed it like
what
in all things not rigid clean it out I
think it was the everyone in sort the
perception was you had non-gamers
playing this game that did not represent
it well you know we're not saying that I
think it's not gonna be fun
we're not saying any that stuff we just
say I think if comic-con wouldn't have
happened it would come out this year did
you play the agents of mayhem yet no I
did all right when you get a chance to I
would like for you to just you know rent
it go to Red Box get it or whatever
because of agents of a.m. I think no no
I feel the comic-con was the nail in the
coffin that they had yes yeah Phil still
said after that stream that they would
have they would have a better demo or
Gamescom so someone probably stuck in
that room every said that was like why
did you save more interesting than
anything they showed at Gamescom well
what happened
between June 11th when they said
crackdowns come in November 7th and last
week or whatever when they delayed
crackdown 3 what changed in two months
time for them to be like it needs to be
delayed you know like that there is that
rumor that was going around that uh
maybe you know if that removes correct
that the multiplayer was going to be
delayed maybe they got to the point
where they were taking such a hit from
crackdown they realized it wasn't worth
delaying the multiplayer and taking more
of a hit on that game and that that's
kind of that's kind of what I thought
was that you know like I think maybe
even ages man may have had something to
do with it but hear me out on this like
gopher so like I had heard that
multiplayer wasn't gonna make it for the
holiday right and they were gonna delay
it
single-player and co-op 2017 launched
with the system multiplayer in 2018
that's something I had heard
and then agents of mayhem comes out and
gets trashed it stretched because it
doesn't have any multiplayer there's
people at Microsoft maybe looking and
like yo without multiplayer atm it's got
trashed maybe we should wait until that
and launch it next year give it a visual
upgrade boost and launch it as a full
product and you know what is a valid
theory and you know let's be honest here
you know regardless how what kind of you
know state it being quite a crackdown
being delayed put the 2017 you know line
up to save the crackdown that had to be
delay it had to be it had to be but I
agree I think I think Lauren is on to
something because you know besides like
I said the motor play is such a complex
component and then the thing actually I
care about that I don't see a lot of
people talking about more excited about
4 player co-op mission I didn't see any
of that so that was another thing where
I was just like where are is that it was
just too much not being shown Lord King
lost our did you jump in and we before
we go to the next one my thing on the
gamescom thing just real quick on it and
I'm not gonna bash it because I went in
on Twitter I went in on Twitter because
I was thoroughly disgusted at what was
being presented
shoutout to AC bungles for doing our
bang out job it was fantastic that you
hold it together for as hard as you held
it together I fell for you I'm going up
there like I felt for every developer
that had to sit up there and go through
that I felt for you um but again like
they said this it's an event
um I didn't like the little sidebars the
little comical crap I hated it it was
you was they would turn my stomach it's
on my stomach to the point
I think unease things as they people
were making fun of the skittle bow when
my daughter sister says you know does
she know about games there you go
I said wow you know because the the the
developer from cuphead was there and she
really wanted to get technical
about the game but she didn't have the
outlet to do so and the questions
weren't skewed in the way that they can
she was able to get that across ROM so I
thought that was honestly the worst
interview for cuphead that I've ever
seen but they'd never put her to the
forefront before they do it now and I'm
like you don't need to sell the game now
everybody's in on cuphead like why would
you it was like a blatant attempt to do
that and in every question you wish it
was talking about real quick that before
they give it back you're looking before
when it's this weird a subject cut head
not a gamete we talked about this
what some would know online to coop
those guys you know they went am here
bro you know I don't want to minimize
what they did to get that game out here
and they did make an announcement that I
guess it would come later I hope that
feature does launch later as you know I
like a patch when when the funding is
there maybe the funding isn't there you
would say something in reference to our
cut gem sorry well I was I was the same
like they did mention that they would
look into the feasibility of adding
online co-op after the game launched see
if it's possible you know it's not like
that's gonna hurt the shows drastically
but you know having that is online co-op
and couch co-op in couch coves the
difference between sell in a couple
thousand and a couple million if we cry
loud enough unbeliever to come and you
know get on Twitter you play yours a
fabulous game if only but just start
hash tagging everything if only online
co-op but like I said I
I have to go to Gamescom next year and
I'm we're gonna go iron Lords will be at
Gamescom not yet um to get the
experience to feel that you know but did
it come across well no I but they did
exactly what I thought they was gonna do
just like I said there was gonna give
you dates price everything all that
stuff you had the price you had the
dates you you're ready to go get your
pre-orders get everything that's it and
then it was gonna give you the list of
the games and enhancements yeah so well
that's what we got on this topic listen
keep this thing moving slow ah she's I'm
up so I wanted to bring this to the
lords in the round table something near
and dear to my heart
Shenmue 3 Andromeda yes so as that staff
knows if you talked about kiss up
briefly on rgm last night shout out to
our Jean podcast as great podcast you
guys should check it out
um yeah I mean Lauren I'm a Sega kid you
know I grew up with the Master System
did a Genesis and that last hurrah for
me Lauren was that Dreamcast I loved me
that dream Jack's and I'll never forget
what King and I he showed me he came
over and I believe you had the Japanese
version at the time and you brought that
Shenmue to my house that thing's got a
keep in mind people fall this is og talk
now for what Shenmue represented think
of a game in this term with Tekken 7 s
character models first time cuz Virtua
Fighter and am-2 was like the game
designing polygons and fighting game
polygons and graphics right you know who
world where you had to go to get a job
you had to work and we figured this game
looks so beautiful I'll never forget the
opening cinematic
with Landy and he kills your father
again we love right we're fan of that
kung fu flick error so not only was the
martial arts represented right the
graphics were amazing and it was really
kinda like the first open world for its
time then you go to the shops
you had arcade transition like of hang
on and Space Harrier in like a pseudo
arcade in the in the in the game where
you can play these emulated versions it
was just so many things going on with
this game it was very ambitious and I
never felt like wow this game was a game
changer and you Suzuki let me just put
it for all the record that's my heart
that's i'ma say kid that's one of the
guys that get me into gaming you know
the all those games that hang on shout
runs a Shinobi's all of that like that's
my history so when Shenmue obviously was
announced on the PlayStation experience
Phase III
it's very emotional for me I'm like okay
it bringing back something that's near
and dear they got the kick start I'm
like okay all right I see where they
going low in my feelings it wasn't on
xbox but okay and this thing has gone
dark for a couple of years you know
speak them up a station bredrin just
shout out to lino Lord Jae Bari you know
a lot of my Sony guys I hit him up like
what's going on you know give me some
updates you know one behold the trailer
releases and needless to say those
facial expanded nations were in
understand they were not they were no
bueno
there's the mouth where did the millions
go exactly what's funny is I remember
the Kickstarter goals like each million
had a goal we didn't add this at this so
I'm checking I'm like did we not reach
the facial animation magic number y'all
like what's going on out here so again
you know for clarity you know obviously
that the internet went haywire with a
shout out the lone anchorman here
the funniest tweets going with like Rio
same fate since my happy sad no he came
for me roasted my heart on that one I
was funny I had to take the El but um
you know the only thing I want to bring
to the loss is that recently an article
did come out my hero and he was with a
Japanese magazine I believe the website
game watch impress and now he basically
stating that because the magazine kind
of got him like hey let's go know what
those facial expressions not that will
they change and then Suzuki pretty much
said yes that the trailer that they
didn't put in the facial expressions and
they said it till the model make the
trailer them exactly don't even legs you
know I'm going in to exactly so he says
until a month ago we had put in the face
for animation but for the moment they've
been removed slow the trail which I
thought was strange it strange but I
just want to bring it to the Lord's I
don't know how much Shin will affects
you guys I want to start off with Lord
Ram because I know he talks Sega you
know what was your feeling about it also
have you have any shinwoo connection at
all and if not just switch over to this
whole long cake I was abroad at sea I
presented this beautiful game to you
back then and we we were so engrossed
with the visuals that we had to figure
out how to get a job what we had to do
next what triggered what so it was trial
and error and and lore Cognito and I we
labor it was a labor of love for that
game we labor like I came up we kept
playing we kept playing we kept
hammering at it and till we saw to
figure out how to get the crane how to
get the job how to fight this guy and
the cuties dog that was the cute piece
of news we have we seen them now fast
forward to now when I saw that trailer I
said
Jesus this game looks the same way they
didn't up grade anything maybe as a
particle effect someplace then I said
they're robbing us where's my money at
that's this this where's my cash going
what's going on here somebody's still
somebody's in Cancun on my dollar they
doing a premium style somebody's doing a
premium style on my dollar and I'm
trying to figure out who did it is the
facial animation guys still in Bahamas
give me my face you know when the duel
kicked him in the head he spun around
and he had the master Maul face give me
my money back I swear I swear they
better not release that game with that
dude with the master mall face this
complete is the same exact game all they
did was uh president no lord sauvé you
have a connection to this title yes I do
guys I am a Sega kid through and through
Master System Genesis and I think I
think even more than you guys like I
stuck I stuck with the Saturn on the
Saturn my 2d fighters like I was all oh
no remember bu was down the same way
that's when I started yeah you you you
stepped off the platform you hope you
will laugh
you'll help me on the toshinden and the
PlayStation Elizabeth and to be honest
man that jumped when we got that
Dreamcast and even before the symbol
when we threw on Soul Calibur and we
were playing Soul Calibur the Japanese
version once aa system launched here we
were just blown away by that system like
they did everything right with that
system they you know the only the only
thing is that they released it at a time
where it was an awkward in-between sort
of generation between generations yeah
and it was gonna get steamrolled but
what came after it but to be honest I
was one of the greatest systems ever
dashing like you guys said it was a
revelation for a lot of people gameplay
wise it wasn't anything super special in
terms of you know actual actions that
you did people a lot of people weren't
happy with cuties and whatnot but the
experience that have provided um
the sort of real world kind of banality
of day-to-day stuff but it was cool
because you never did that in the game
it was like really that you let me do
this like it's what game would allow you
to do that so it was a little
disheartening to see this video again we
talked about it last night like what if
what if this is what it is and they just
want to hearken back to the old games of
the case he said the project graph is
like please make sure to dress me I
don't know if we need to temper our
expectations for what we expect from
somewhere and I know they even said this
at the onset like and I heard a lot of
the gaming press talk about this when
they first announced it temper your
expectations for what this is gonna be
this is not gonna be you know the
Shenmue 3
you know slack
The Witcher 3 like you're not getting
that little detail don't think you're
getting that yeah I think with Shenmue
even if you sort of condensed the world
a little bit and just make the things
that you do in the world
interesting allow you to go into like
buildings and stuff like that and kind
of create an in-depth since experience
that way without necessarily having to
make it a vast world I think you have a
winner there as long as the story's
tight and everything is tight in it
finally closes out you know real story
so they need to focus on to give to give
good experience within what they're able
to do don't let too much loss are oh
this is it am I asking too much for
better character that's the question
bring that up because the question is
it's almost like I hate to say this but
it's like obviously you know where I got
Suzuki son know where I'm riding him is
it like an old fighter with a dinosaur
and we've heard rumors
during the Shenmue development he blew
the budget like his shins are so crazy
he had the friction with Sega's because
dogs you join it's too expensive
you know I mean and it was an intern and
that's why I guess it wasn't around for
that era but did you think when you saw
this the animations are unacceptable and
that's the only call my title interest
you in any bit oh it's just nothing you
would never buy I'd rather play quantum
break
it's the young wolf so he represents a
generation that didn't grow around you
showing you know someone that that you
know wasn't old enough to comprehend the
game towards fullest and this is what
you're showing the new installment it's
not making me one even looking at it so
this is it's like you know there's
there's a franchise that I've always
loved it's gone way of the samurai and
you know I haven't seen that game in
like a decade so I love Lord addict what
if they gave you um Shenmue 1 & 2 a
little up res and give you the backstory
would you would you care to get into the
backstory and then play part 300 looking
like that okay it's like what's the
point in play like the way you're
describing it what a to look better than
three I'm such a fan it's a shame you
know if you know what I it has to come
out on the summer heat you know when
they you know what's the what if like
summer heat gains of slashing prices 595
didn't call me man you got the Mohawk
thing he's got to mess them all be bad
but we are going to listen this is
coming we got a move our time to
coincide with you know the Lord's Day
football day um but I gotta tell you
guys I played that Manning oh man it is
incredible but let me preface this guy's
uh
you know EA has been taking this big
leap with um whoa the Frostbite engine
this is this is the this is their joint
you know so we all were with the Unreal
Engine the Unreal Engine has it did us
well Unreal Engine 2 it was so great it
did so many different things and was
fantastic but you know EA say yo it's
time for it's time for us to take this
do this in-house let's keep this money
in our pockets you know stop paying
these royalties to these people let's
develop our own stuff they don't work
well for the FIFO Pfeiffer you know and
then they say you know let's put it for
the need for speed
photorealistic
engine battle film alright
know when it got to battlefield you said
battlefield is beautiful but it had a
little things going on you saw a little
something use like what's that you saw
what's that over there that don't look
straight that looks alright
then you got to mass effects on drama
that's right probably by the Frostbite
and what's over they faces why are you
walking like that there's something
wrong oh man there's frostbite engine ok
so I'm playing on Madden my children
sitting there and heavily invested in
that story mole oh I'm not gonna front
I'm like please you gotta make the team
I made a choice and it was like oh damn
I'm like nah but that's my dude I'm not
gonna leave my do like that so a lot of
decisions I liked it the Sun here comes
the animations this force by an engine
this is the growing pains guys you guys
not seeing a lot of clipping you're
gonna start seeing animations me and
said daddy why is his hands going
through his body like that
you know when you look over at your kid
and you like oh oh baby um you know this
is this is the demo you know where your
[Applause]
cows over there working for EA for all
anime what controller to frostbite let
me tell you this is where God works
so I finished that that part the long
shot they give you a little bit like ah
get your feet wet latest I gotta play
this part I said let me play the game
let me play you know my Jets vs so uh so
I wasn't allowed to do that but I was a
allowed to play whoever they pick I
picked my team I'm like I wanted to play
with my chest got my Jets in there I
said um oh I saw our quarterback more
you lose
but then you know Madden is known for
the presentation mm-hmm presentation
took a hit really oh the fraud you not
feeling well my feeling is the
animations mmm the animations it reminds
me of when we was playing 2k football
remember the first time we got it and
the arms were too long a summer subtle
it didn't look right it's so much more
yeah and didn't they were doing weird
things it's like the in-between
animations like they don't know what
they do they got like Restless arms or
something it's always kind of had that
way it's kind of like these like so it's
even more emphasized
yes because as the growing pains of
switching this engine you know um
I'm sorry some of the animations didn't
make it they didn't make it into this
copy let me tell you it wasn't about
losing because I said I don't really
care about this part of the game which
is the whole thing long shot that's what
I care about because the long shot it
seems that this frostbite engine does
everything else really well but when it
comes to animations of non inanimate
objects like cars and stuff like that
that's where the problems start to kick
in my thing is have you guys experienced
this Madden um do you see this frostbite
engine as a detriment to Madden should
they go back to the Unreal jumping
shelter brings back but um yeah I just
you know I'm a magnet obviously it's one
of those things a man I get it kind of
every other year edition was really cool
you know I played up into the point
where they starting to do the show or
whatever
I like the emotional choices it
definitely felt like oh so like a
telltale game right you know little
cuties in certain parts you got the
emotional decision which you made and
stuff like that so that's cool
as pause it you like games yeah I get
maybe you know this I'm so conditioned
to Madden stuff what I call them like
Madden isms I guess I'm the wrong person
to ask
because I've always played three games
and ever touches it again my tech family
we're doing a big on what you'd call a
franchise everybody's in it you know
fames talking and talk so we gotta get
at him you know everybody's in it
what's funny is look how you'll be doing
that a lot I remember like channel 5 for
some reason you guys be hyping games
I've never seen you play week after
comes
I will never forget the amount of hype
that this game God and then I isn't that
like it wasn't even a weak fam it was
like three days that's a whole nother
story there's this time when games come
out in the Sun this siege the siege and
it's all I got
I play DC I still play to see shout out
to anchor man they got a crew that
playable CDs a game you just gotta play
with people you kid yeah I challenge the
multi-verse iron Lords podcast the
multi-variable succeed come back oh
let's do it let's do it oh let's do but
yeah back to back to your point I mean
you know it looks like Manning to me
just you know some betters facial
animations here in there I didn't know
Sarah was the detraction of the
Frostbite but that's just me you know I
guess I'm wrong I will tell you to go
play last year's version all right we're
good not to jump off topic cuz I know
Lauren is back Randy in the building yes
sir I am back alright now I'll shout out
the Lord you all the Brit the premium
Brits of the jet the free will visit the
jet you're gonna bring it back around
I know you miss a little bit last topic
and I know you're a sick kid so we'll
bring it back
um Shenmue 3 / Andromeda I will into a
diatribe about me and my feelings about
you know the game how much he meant to
me and then I went into obviously the
facial animations bit were you a Shenmue
guy if so explain if not and then also
about the current product that you've
seen your opinions so it this is where
we're gonna differ here because I've
never played yes never play this is the
one and I think to say and I think the
new one looks like straight
original dromeda that much crap for
their facial animations and oh boy I
hope they're ready to dish it out for
some Shamu 3 I really think the original
fable looks better than Sony tried it
out and like did Sony not put any money
like was this like this I'm confused
about the story and finding it they're
not they're literally just presenting it
somebody's running around with this
money ran a low rent somebody has got
our money and it is the facial animation
guys and he's in the Bahamas right now
taking my time so yeah it was a sad
thing in the discussion ran which is
that if Lord Suzuki son if he's just
lost his Todd show was just you know one
of those well should be I mean he's
probably in over his head
look it's like the same thing with valve
right they're never going to make
half-life 3 because what you think
half-life 3 should should be is never
gonna like they're never gonna live up
to the expectations you have of the game
in oh you mean like Final Fantasy 7
yeah three like I know people are super
excited to get it back but the
expectations of that game what you've
dreamt about for all these years that
game that they're gonna put out is never
had a chance of living up to those
expectations these are fair assessment
is it's not even worse because you're
gonna look and be like okay we'll come
back on the Dreamcast I guess I brought
up went to a Japanese website he watch
impress and they they kind of got him
like they said that the character
animations are still the facial you know
fix is this part of the game and he
basically came out he said that they
have not put in the facial animations
until a month ago they had them but for
the moment they've been removed so like
I agree with all addict
why would you show that tree yeah why
was pretty much like like he's trying to
like blame it on oh the Department
matter no why our PR team is this like I
gave him the game and then they looked
at it was like we good so you know what
I let it go out it got to the point that
I don't know if you went to the
Kickstarter page they have like each
monetary goal I was checking the facial
animations were at like the three
million block or if it was not reached
that's what I thought maybe I was like
oh man
but unfortunately yeah this is what he's
running for you like god I don't want to
like crush anybody's dreams here I'm
just gonna say I have no interest in the
game whatsoever
back to look King let's finish up as mad
and although James
I will gun for you like no other I will
give you the premium bullets and
rainbows succeed understand this is true
that's them
I got nothing else to say on that matter
and unless Lord Ram wants to talk about
the the animations and then in the bad
transition from the Frostbite engine i
think the force bite engine is hitting
its upper limits as far as Mass Effect
Andromeda and this Madden do I think the
teams need another year I don't think
mass affects gifts that other year but
you know matters coming on next year
will they iron out these things I hope
so but I think it's a rough draft this
year I hear long shots of good mode
though shots good alright so we
apologize Lord I forget about your
sports prowess here back then I mean I
know I'm just gonna say past but I had
at least say
I think I have as much violent no iron
lures podcast every individual member
and our guest chooses a topic we have
our own little chat that the topic is
talked about throughout the week so you
know first thing I see is the mad thing
I was like well I ain't gonna talk about
that the next day I see the Shenmue
thing I was like well this podcast is
gonna suck for me what's up baby
appreciate you man but that like button
and I appreciate you guys yeah a lot
attic up zone well I mean you know when
it comes to we we definitely we we do
this show to give you guys an
entertaining show you know they they get
it they get onto me for saying past but
like I think it's a comedic thing like
you know your boy you know your boy
added go just go pass on topics he
thinks is trash and I think man's trash
anything you'd like to add to you this
maddening before you move on to the less
well I think for me I haven't played a
football game extensively since like Joe
Montana sports talk football under
chances oh my god yeah but I will say
this I think longshot is a mode that
needs to survive and go on to other
games I haven't I'm a baseball game and
I much as I love the show I haven't
played the show in like three years
because it just seems a me to me and
even rode to the show they've made
improvements to that to sort of you
don't make you feel like you're you're
bringing up the up year I'm sorry do you
check your Twitter account get into this
final topic and um obviously Gamescom
happened this week and Bungie had a
tremendous presence there and we had the
lot of destiny to info blast we had
trailers we had
oh so Cara are you gonna start trouble
already you coming from you already
yes oh it's me got it we got a lot of
huge information obviously we know our
in-laws podcast really where destiny
podcast gotta talk a little destiny it's
been a little bit last week didn't get a
chance with hip hop but um did the
Lord's first catch any of this arm stuff
let's start off with a Lord Randolph
resident destiny expert slash guru all
the Lords here Lord addict Lord King
Lord Sovereign Lord kognito I wanted to
get your input on this because I don't
know what to think
now okay guys our destiny lovers correct
was actually I'm very critical of
destiny I could jumped on all the time
over oh you know I'm critical of Xbox
but I love Xbox you know you can be
critical obviously so the thing that
stuck out to me was those destiny to
trophy lists know about that like like
13 trophies no flawless raider trophy no
trophy for beating the raid on hard
well here's we you know even if they do
that you know lore Cognito has went
completely south this whole truck
evening in the past month prior to this
month i think everyone at higher laws
would not care to bits about the
achievements like they're cooling on but
like I do have concern that and you know
I'm hoping they go on a casual thing on
achievements and not gameplay I hope
they don't make everything casual eyes
to a point in the game flow like look
when it comes to it's like the hardest
game mode they need that Prestige Mode
I'm hoping that is the hardcore mode and
you know hard is like you just born
which is shout out the Lord CAC is the
king of a destiny can even offer claim
on show he is inferring that that is
what exactly what they're doing it that
Prestige Mode is going to they're gonna
like prestige nightfalls how crazy like
the knife fall already in itself is
insane
put on bed leg then I'll jump in so you
know I want this stuff to be right and
you know there's a lot of speculation
going on right now about what exactly it
means you know the the raid is called
belly the bee bees so we don't know you
know the lava it's both the the rights
called Leviathan so you know when you
think of Leviathan you think of sea
serpent and you know I hopefully like
you know you know shout-out to HD he
when he was on the show he brought up
that don't be surprised if the raid is
not cabal so you know going off that
feedback you know I'm trying to keep my
mindset like not can be completely right
towards the Cabal so I'm trying to keep
like you know an open perspective of
where this right can go so I'm really
hoping that you know maybe they bring in
some lore because you know a lot of
people don't know this because Bungie is
extremely bad it at explaining anything
when it comes to destiny you know they'd
rather give that old go on our website
and look at them and know story so you
know when it comes when it comes to that
I want them that out to locale yeah Lord
cows in the building but you know I want
them to be more upfront about what's
going on I want into it and it's looking
like they did you know take our input on
a lot of aspects you know a lot of
people see this is destiny 1.5 but
people who put a lot of time in a
destiny one realizes that they took a
lot of player feedback and changed a lot
people who wouldn't know this the entire
multiplayer is nothing like the original
destiny to was literally it was like it
was made by the players well it helps to
me know I mean I'm very grateful because
now I can get that participation trophy
that called me a hater yes my all-time
favorite developer they created my
favorite friend
Chai's there was no game I was more
excited for the original destiny ever
like why did that game to be so good and
the gameplay was top-notch people are
gonna hate me when I say this but I
think 343 makes better halos multiplayer
with two on point I'm sorry
I mean halo 5 multiplayer is I'm not
like you know is I get that the story's
a huge impact but when I play Halo it's
the habit it's to have a dapple story
and to be all on the multiplayer
multiplayer is better than all bungees
multi players except for two but you
know I just say just got to work that
story kinks out I love I love Bungie and
I destiny like the gameplay is top-notch
like up in the class the shooting the
jumping the ability is like that 30
seconds okay commands hating on you
right now say it again Lord I say about
that gun place one more time with your
chest I'm saying commands in the chat
hey hey but anchorman loves fallout 4
gunplay I mean come on is he salty that
the iron Lords is about to stop him and
see so you know play mechanics
first-person shooters destiny is right
there and call of duty if not better
Oh like Oh strictly gameplay mechanics
however with that said the core around
destiny like the idea of doing the same
strikes a million times to grind out
stuff I just can't get behind you stay
in a way week uh mm-hmm
well my buddy's gonna be getting I
wouldn't I wouldn't spend my own money
on it watch a game show
like it's 95% of his library is my
library you can't take one game account
like 500 from that one game I couldn't
rightfully give Bungie my money this
time yes I am what's going on guys all
right here we go we got we got take
royalty nobility Kings in the building
James here just wanted to chat a little
bit of whatever see how everything was
going with the show show was great
awesome I want to thank everybody for
the support and support in iron ore
podcast that's killing it by the way for
you to stop on the show as well as
always love you haven't having you here
for destiny I just want to get my
opinion out for destiny I agree with
Rand I think I think Disney's gunplay is
superb
you can close may by you know before
three because the Halos gonna play a
superb me and you could toe is very
inspired nothing to say because he
hasn't been playing for losses he took
that l at e3 cuz I wanna bet he has a
buddy a lot of gets fixed cow you were
you heard what he said did you he's
praying that they even within two
doesn't get delay because if that means
he can't play Wolfenstein it does have
because they would be let the look
hopefully that falls in my favor I
really hope that happens but he's
getting off easy with this
almost pretty high that was my life bro
that that was my life the largest but
light ranch said with destiny I love
destiny I think the bay met irritating
me in the mall so it did was the
grimoires
I'm like I was it was almost like
destiny had became elderscrolls it's
like damn I gotta read all these books
just to find out what's going on with
the story
they had fine without what was going so
I had to go all flan to another place to
find out what was going on with the
story not even actually what was
happening in the game so that was my one
thanks like the website was complicated
it wasn't easy either yeah before I head
out cuz I don't want interrupt the show
you guys keep an eye out
we got a patreon coming very soon for
all the people out there who want to
support us what what we're trying to do
is bring you guys quality content that
exceeds the value I'm saying there you
be that party out there trying to hit
you with stuff like you know join up
we'll play games with you join up and
we'll get if you were shout out things
like that and though we have those
things at the lowest tiers
um we're definitely bringing some things
that you guys will truly enjoy like
calling kids smooth and cursing him out
one of our hey what about this you can
call kids smooth if you don't agree with
any show that he does at a particular
time of day it gave him a piece of your
my perfect 101 listen this page on this
page who you are about to be the hottest
page hang on out of everybody
to agree to it this is what makes it
even doper kid is putting his sanity on
the line for you guys we called but we
call it the smooth operator line anchor
and in Rainbow six and crushin yeah we
have we got it here where you can
challenge any tic member in any game
streaming what about a tier where you
can call up anchor and Tom Bethesda
games are bad there is a tier where you
can uh you can get a shout out and have
any one of your choice to do the
shout-out and maybe your name says
Bethesda sucks I mean how do I know that
like we have it we have a small tear
very small tear under five bucks where
you can get a shout your name shout out
by anybody you want on any show any way
you want it to be shout it out so we can
be live shout out to the king of so and
so and so yadda yadda yadda however you
wanted to be shot out we got to do it
look we've got some love we got we got
private service comment when you can
just point out we all be on that you'll
pay dollars don't be premium everyone
watching make Lord King play the
impossible game we're gonna see we get
the I or escort fear where we want to be
as water through Ray's we got that we
will definitely definitely
September 1st keep an eye out for that
I'm going to announce it on the on the
channel Twitter Facebook everywhere we
get so you guys want to sign up there
was a dollar two dollars whatever just
go ahead and support we greatly
appreciate it's gonna go a long way to
it seems build us up absolutely need
your opinion
did you see any of the trailers of the
destiny to stuff this for me the most
important stuff is the story stuff like
I said like I'm gonna be there day one
with you guys like I'm not taking off
from work I'll be there all day but I
know they're moving forward when it
comes to them but you guys so the story
stuff is most important to me like oh I
miss touring with you now what's off to
his first read with the Lords what'd he
do is first thing goes the way it's
supposed to go like have you know no
sauce no wonder all right have you ever
done a raid though you know it dude
no it Oh
I have close to 600 hours on destiny
100k okay so I get to your question
raised did you do I'm just curious I did
while the first one which was probably
the best one in my opinion about the
glass I mean do crota because I didn't
come back and well I did crota later but
no I came back to destiny when taking
king came out and I'll actually Volvos I
really enjoyed the taken king expansion
I thought it was well done and I thought
that race works was a phenomenal yeah I
don't know how many times I did the orcs
raid but after that I got was the one
after that the expansion after that was
you know I did the story and then never
played it again like yeah in relevant
raid where the antagonist made no sense
yeah you didn't miss but it was it was a
fun but it was it was lame how they did
how they incorporated it into the actual
story and I remember God uses lawless
Raider and my hands are [ __ ] especially
like one of the car it was actually hard
when you couldn't like just go back
super easily right when do you fall to
class and that was hard
legit yeah but when you're with the iron
Lords you know we do that flawlessly all
the time because we I think we went left
we didn't a lot of us an answer question
which was I do feel yeah I am I do feel
a way that the achievements have been
casualized that flawless rate
achievement meant a lot
I remember truck like you said long ran
trying to get dad your hands are
sweating you know you're doing all that
stuff so you but one could hope I mean I
don't I don't know I mean pretty much
all them has been released I know the
raid one kind of leaked and that kind of
stuff one would hope that you know they
got the harder difficulties to stuffed
if there's some type of wood but it kind
of does something that even the ones for
a heart-to-heart raided so you can just
do like hard nightfall you know yeah
right yeah absolutely right I'm very
surprised by that and it definitely
seemed like a casualized achievement
list we know the DLCs coming so you know
they add some two seconds Lord King I
want to see hash tag useless in the
comment section let me tell you why I
don't feel her first of all she borrowed
it was why she still got you taken King
when you got to stormcaller
ability in that sequence when she's
talking to you about harnessing that
electricity and that energy that to me
connected me with the character I felt
like okay this is what I'm talking about
yo Lord addict you stupid team useless
and check are you ridiculous for me
going back to that story stuff for me
the
interesting thing that I saw was that
other character that Hawthorne I listen
this neighbor because it just felt like
to me like you know she's not really
feeling the Guardians you guys you
without the light now and you guys
whining and crying and we've ballooned
out life like I'm not feeling you right
now so to me again that's that's cool
story sucks water cuz you rock a poncho
doe which class do you run one you get
that out to me first
what type of me what class I run I mean
the one and only Titan man so you're
tight so I'm assuming now did you see
the different Vanguard trailers for
Sawalha Cade and I coordinate now I mean
I played I played the beta which I
enjoyed the story segments of that game
so that's it that kind of went on a
media blackout for it after gotcha okay
so you gonna see the newest trailers
where they try to give you like a little
backstory each fan you know alright when
you get a chance we'll do this later
offline watch all three and in your shut
up everybody 46 strong everybody hit
that like and everything um what I
wanted to do is we going to talk about
um first of all the patreon it we
already know so the look would you go
look bring that out there's a lot of
stuff going on that you mean so make
sure you guys support that know like it
so all yeah we're gonna do these outros
right quick and that's one question
my reaction what do you think about this
rumor about Bethesda making a game of
Thrones RPG Oh target's website that's
how people found it tonight's the finale
for Game of Thrones is there a chance
baby they announced this Bethesda RPG
set in a game of Thrones universe
you mean sky and Game of Thrones edition
I mean whatever I mean I don't know I
don't know this is this is a good one I
mean if they saying it's like a target
incorrect listing it may be some true to
it I'm surprised see when when when lord
anchor doesn't know I get concerned of
Airport as he put the article up in
Forbes and I did see it so he's running
behind it we'll see I mean I think if it
is true Wow what what a game that could
be yeah I don't want it to do any
existing storylines of character just
kind of inhabit the world and give me
something new within that universe if it
was set during Robert's rebellion you
know right before oh that would be you'd
have all the same characters but in
different spots and it was it's a
prequel to the you know the story I'll
that'd be so cool the many-faced God
it's just some of that in this thing uh
my first of all shout out the Lord Ram
for coming through we really appreciate
you you know we had a great time I love
what you do where can the fine people
find you in these days yeah I mean if
people want to check out the daily
videos that I do drop you can check that
out in YouTube which is youtube.com
slash R and L 419 all the relevant
social media links will be right there
you know Twitter and all those all that
other fun stuff is basically on that on
that site but I had a great time with
you guys a lot of fun man
like much higher rate : I'm feeling good
that we got you link in the description
please check out his channel check out
his content great daily videos from a
balanced perspective there's no traded
and no community he's a gamer y'all get
out your feelings so you got to put that
out there my shout out the Lord rain and
the man with the million for showing us
Lord addict Michaels with the coal most
what's going on I can actually talk
about a yeah I'm going to leave that I
mean they've already announced it on
Twitter so I slept in like 19 hours this
is a great day this is a great day shut
up the Louis move kiss moving the crew
cycle game of pain two independent love
your love what you guys are doing over
there people people getting some weird
thing over there with Panda they're
putting Panda emojis in the comments
she's gotta follow you make sure you
wrap that paper so wedding it yeah I
still popping off at Tuesday's at what
times Tuesdays at 7:30 to 8:00 just
whenever kid decides to go live but you
know definitely go over there and check
that out
I'm gonna talk to kid about having a
special episode this uh this Tuesday I'm
gonna see if he'll name it the year the
hell I give the sillies off for that cuz
I created how that conversation goes
we're too hard on Xbox but you know
we'll see how that goes
but definitely check that out it's like
I said I'm gonna let kid and cow
you know officially announce from the
debut is gonna happen because it's not
really my place to say thanks but uh
appreciate you guys for coming around I
want to thank a man at the million one
more time for coming through who's
definitely an honor to have you on
you've officially been knighted to the
to Lord status you know the year of the
allergists say there's more words in the
year of the alb
than Microsoft was dropping exclusives
for words if I say that is no way in
hell but you know definitely you know
tune in you know I appreciate anyone
that hasn't liked the podcast definitely
like it shows appreciation shows you
know definitely shows that your support
in the podcast I appreciate all the ones
that came through think we had up to 70
68 69 people in the pod in that podcast
indefinitely uh we out so uh next Louis
sovereign waking to find people find
yourself oh yeah first and foremost
shout-out to Lord Ram for coming through
and we really appreciate it and the
other people can find me where they
always do or don't find me yes sir the
Xbox Live P smbx our one word and Lord
saw io p on Twitter and the premium
gamer himself more King
let's shout out to the man with the
million you got to really put this in
perspective they held them back before
you got a chance to achieve this book
that's even a greater accomplishment to
be honest with you when I saw it it was
like a you know beautiful I'm glad he's
on the show I was like he was like I
need to have this dude on a serious note
I need all you PlayStation dues to add
me xbox 360 low one I really don't have
any friends
Megatron you might want to go to the
beginning of the podcast just say yeah
I'm up with my outros we have a problem
I gotta give a shout-out to Lord all um
for my Maron experience my football
Ariane's he facilitated my greatest
experience is in football so this
football season is about to kick off the
on count preseason and every football
season kicks off I think of Lord Paul
because he actually hooked me up with my
greatest football experience
good luck Nate oh hey Inuyasha
you know where to find me but I just
want to address a couple of man Lord
Megatron in to chat up looking for him
earlier
August achievement month and let's just
say I see what you're trying to do bro
see I got my eyes on you make a chart I
need this so here you go talk this must
be afraid of the fire control it down oh
no you're big Casey shoutout to the
landlords and Randy's on vacation but he
still can't do the show love shut up the
brat make sure you support him with
everything but I do want to bring for me
and I saw someone donated and said
something about fact of X outs that
people should try appreciate the
donations always definitely will help be
in a circle Network shout-out to that
dude I you know it was so far gone I
can't find out who was so whoever it was
I apologize I didn't get to it sooner
but thanks for the donation no doubt and
like I said I'll be here I can say
spreading that gaming realist not
telling me what you wanna hear what you
need to hear guess shout the Lord Ram
for coming through everybody great show
the chat was lit as always make sure you
hit that like subscribe I'll pee on all
the media outlets in a circle YouTube
iTunes SoundCloud remember all your Xbox
guys is a SoundCloud app you can
download them in the background but on
that note we're gonna end this thing
peace